sarenza ou par un mot
à la bouche pendant les ting âge
est-ce que par amour pour lui vous
seriez prête à vous déguiser en est je
regarde
est-ce que par amour pour lui vous
seriez prête à arrêter de chanter non
non est ce que vous seriez prêtre par
amour à vous convertir à l'islam et à
passer votre vie voit les noms n'ont
voulu n'est pas tant que ça finalement
en fait non
est ce que vous seriez prête par amour à
vous faire refaire les seins non et
parmi
vous seriez prête à prendre 17 kg qui
vous le demandait nom et par gourmandise
bien sûr ça oui
vous seriez prête paramo a caché le
corps de quelqu'un qui vient de tuer
non non est-ce que par amour vous
accepteriez qu'il est une maîtresse
dont vous soyez pas d'accord pour vivre
à trois avec la maîtresse non point
physiquement
aïe aïe aïe est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à faire des partouzes
non c'est la dernière question c'est la
pire kelly vous êtes prête
est ce que vous seriez prêtre par amour
à devenir son esclave sexuelle
alors
bah oui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux